l'horizon vide de ce prolonge s'étale et
finit par fondre ses terrains crédieux
dans la couleur jaune de la plage le sol
devient plus ferme une odeur salée vous
arrive on dirait un désert dont la mère
s'est retirée les langues de sable
longues aplatites sur l'autre ce
continuant à définir par des plans
indestins ce rides comme une onde sous
de grande ligne courbe arabesque géante
que le vent s'amuse à dessiner sur leur
surface
les flots sont loin si reculés qu'on ne
les voit plus qu'on n'entend pas leur
bruit
mais je ne sais quelle vague murmure
insaisissable
aérien comme la voie même de la solitude
qui n'est peut-être que l'étourdissement
de ce silence
c'est beau monsieur Gigant
aujourd'hui il y a moins de brouillard
que tous ces jours il est bien plus beau
plus joli il a l'air tout près de nous
là il y a 7 km en ligne droite 7 km
rien de la brume on a l'impression qu'il
est beaucoup plus loin quand même c'est
pas la même chose et quand il y a des
brouillards souvent on aperçoit que le
haut du Mont-Saint-Michel ou des fois le
bord aujourd'hui les Bleus bleuté mais
des jours il est gris gris sale
toutefois il est marron enfoncé
il est beau
par jour pour le voir d'abord pouvoir ce
qui se passe dans la Bible puisque c'est
mon métier et qu'est-ce qui se passe en
abaisse ce matin pour l'instant il y a
rien c'est calme mais ça ne sera pas
toujours comme ça
qu'est-ce que vous faites avec les
estivants je les conduis au Mont
Saint-Michel passeur le guide des grèves
alors vous les guettez ici avec votre
jumelle
je guide les imprudents c'est plutôt ça
vous êtes né à Genève non je suis né à
Vince c'est le petit pays à côté là
je suis parti dans la marine de bonheur
j'en avais marre de rester là tous les
jeunes et puis
plus tard je me suis marié d'abord je
fais la guerre puis je te blessé
Dunkerque je suis revenu ici et puis je
reste là
que j'ai appris la guerre que j'ai
commencé à faire le guide
vous avez voyager loin oh oui pas mal
vous avez dit au revoir des belles baies
mais j'aime mieux la mienne
j'ai remplacé l'ancien guide qui lui
menait les voitures de Genève les
voitures à chevaux parce que ici à
l'hôtel juin
c'était là que sera semblé tous les
touristes qui voulaient faire la
traversée de la grève et il partait par
exemple 7 8 10 voitures à chevaux avec
deux chevaux quelques fois trois ou
quand il y avait du danger on mettait
trois chevaux et une fois que le danger
au départ était pensé on retire un
cheval et on mettait sur une voiture
ainsi de suite derrière les autres
on est au bec d'Andenne là
et puis alors il y a le monde
après il y a Cancale avec sa pointe que
le coin et puis son fameux phares
puis vous passez la mer et
vous venez là vous avez la pointe de
Champeaux Carole
ur Vanessa Jean Le Thomas dragées jeûner
avec ou qu'on est tout à l'heure c'est à
dire au bec d'antenne
et là vous attendez le client c'est de
là dans cette salle
d'avance nuit en short de préférence et
on part en direction un petit peu à
droite de ton bled
tout à l'heure
et on va jusqu'à presque à la rivière
parce que là il y a des sommes mouvants
à ma droite là où bien les gens il y a
des saveurs
mais c'est souvent sur le passage de des
touristes c'est là ça se termine dans
les tournants des rivières sur les caves
qui se formenta de la mer et qui se
remplit sortira de la mer aussi
c'est exactement comme sur le marché sur
un
comment vous appelez ça un sommier
[Musique]
que je veux dire parce que je suis en
pote et
alors là
et quand quand quelqu'un est pris dans
les sables mouvants et englouti que
devient le corps ou que devient le
bateau qui dans les samouants il
disparaît dans le sable non
on a retrouvé trois ans après on va
retrouver des corps ou qui sont venus
qui ont été dégagés parce que la mère à
jour l'autre jour dégage on a retrouvé
des corps ici là après la guerre on a
retrouvé des corps ici le tronc rien que
le tronc il y a donc
l'abeille il y a des tas de choses
cachées
[Musique]
des briques à anglais il y a la France
et aussi et on sait où se trouve ces
patins oui ils sont on sait où sont mais
pour l'instant ils sont sous les
c'est parce que vous faites le matin un
peu voir s'il y a un petit trésor qui
est remonté à la surface
donc
le sable rentre tout ce qu'il prend
quand même
il y avait quelques
brins de cheveux on aurait dit que tes
collègues comme s'il y avait du
carburant
c'était des trucs comme ça
[Musique]
et elle entend qu'elle avait été
ensoleillée à votre avis il y avait déjà
une pause qui était
ce que l'appel des
terrains des tournants alors c'est là la
mer ralentit il y a des fois elle marche
à 10-15 à l'heure d'autres fois elle
marche à 30 et elle revient à 10-12
c'est comme sur une route c'est la même
chose mais en ligne droite par Marie
daquinoxe ça marche à 30 à l'heure
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on écrit
par la mer quand on est pris par la mer
ça c'est un drôle c'est bien mais en
dehors de ça on va on m'appelle si je
vois si je suis là si vous avez fait
être présent
si je suis là à surveiller que je les
vois j'y vais et en attendant que vous
veniez que qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
vous savez ceux qui sont pris qui sont
seuls
il y en a eu
6 ou 7 de noyer sur 13
c'était pour avoir
pourtant l'hélicoptère est nul tout on a
un petit débat à l'époque on n'avait pas
de sauvetage mais on a foutu adoré
[ __ ] Doris
je crois qu'il a une mort sur les deux
mais le reste
on est les uns et aux autres et c'était
fini la hélicoptère quand il est arrivé
c'était
d'abord il a trouvé de couper le camp
tellement qui se battait entre eux
tellement c'était terrible
Mont-Saint-Michel via Tomblaine oui
à chaque fois plus ou moins quand on me
le demande si on me demande pas je le
fais pas mais généralement tout le monde
est d'accord pour pour faire un petit
arrêt pour monter là haut parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de vue puis revoir ce qu'ils
ont fait les 4 km en haut parce que je
leur dis toujours vous allez voir c'est
formidable
quand ils sont montés là-haut ils
regardent bien ils disent oui parce
qu'en vrai la trace des pas encore une
heure après
on va dire
ça fait un bon bout quoi forcément après
il reste 3 km
et vous la racontez l'histoire de
Tomblaine
dans cette 109 tout ça toute cette
immensité là n'était qu'une forêt et en
709 tout ça c'est
les Anglais étaient déjà avant il avait
les fleurs il avait fait le château les
identifications il voulait le Mont
Saint-Michel
voilà où c'est qu'ils nous ont occupés
ils veulent reprendre c'est pas et c'est
à nous ça c'est quoi
[Musique]
dites-moi il y a un homme célèbre qui
habitait l'îlot c'est le marquis
Tomblaine
mais voilà
Tomblaine a été vendu après il y a une
marquise et elle voulait garder son île
et elle a mis un ermite un pauvre type
balesse elle a il est venu là il a fait
construire une maison il avait son petit
jardin donc il reste un pommier de
figuier à noisetier et tout ça et cet
homme là garder l'île il avait une force
circulaire et tous les jours il allait
11 ans et Michel ils prennent une barre
de porc dans le pot de la rivée et la
moto jusqu'à la porte de l'abbaye ça
reposer il a pas transporté les dames
aussi ah si ça le temps c'était son
boulot
trois sous
que vous avez pas mal rodé dans cette
vidéo tombée
des bouquins
tous les coins les Cavés la moindre
petite fissure dans le rocher je
regardais et je me pensais d'ici là
mais jamais rien trouvé
[Musique]